PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's talk a little bit
about backgrounds again,
but this time we'll see
how you can digitally
change the background.
Now, if you remember
from previous tutorials,
we discussed collecting
interesting backgrounds
to use while making the
images, whether you're
working with the flatbed
scanner or a camera.
But sometimes we're
in a bit of a rush,
as I was while making this
initial image of these two
paper devices.
At the time, I didn't think
about enhancing the image
by including an
interesting background,
maybe to pop out the
devices visually.
So after I made the image
on the flatbed scanner,
this is what we got.
And as we zoom in,
we see a problem.
A bit of a mess with all
sorts of stuff all over it.
That's the price I pay
for being in a hurry
and not cleaning
the glass that day.
Hint, hint.
So because of the
presence of all
of this extraneous
material, we can't simply
select the background with,
let's say, the Magic Wand,
and fill in that selected
area with the color.
The algorithm for
that selection tool
will not select the dirty spots.
And the Paint Bucket
won't do it either.
You see here that the Paint
Bucket filling the background
will not fill in the
dirty bits either.
So that's not going to work.
Let's undo that
with Command-Z. What
I'm going to wind up doing, if I
want to change this background,
is to do it in a different way.
Let me show you how.
We're going to try.
OK.
I'll use the Polygonal Lasso.
And I'll enlarge this
again and move it over.
Watch how I select
what is initially
going to be selecting
just the two devices.
This will take a bit,
so we can speed up
the video a little
bit, not to bore
you too much-- although a little
boredom is good for the soul.
OK.
I'm getting there.
Almost there.
OK.
Here we go.
So what's going on is that I
selected, in fact, actually
a couple of things.
If you really think about it,
yes, I selected the devices,
but if you go to the
inverse of the selection,
that means it will invert
the selection to everything
other than the devices, which
means the full background.
Now that I'm completely
selecting the full background,
I'm going to fill
it with the color
that I previously selected.
It's shown as the
foreground color at 100%.
And here we go.
And the background is filled.
Now I want to show you
a little extra which
I think is worth thinking about.
I'm going to once again
go to the selection menu
and invert the
selection once again, so
that we are, in fact, back
to selecting the devices.
I'm going to open up the
Layers window because I'm
going to show you that we're
working just, at this point,
with one layer.
OK.
Here we go.
Here's the Layers window.
So remember, I first
selected this, inverted
the selection, which
selected the background,
and inverted it back again
to select the devices,
so we are back to
selecting the devices.
I'm now going to make a
layer of these devices
by copying it-- that's
Command-C-- which has just
copied the selected
devices, and then Command-B,
which has pasted
what I just copied,
creating basically another
layer of just the devices.
You can't see that
because the copy layer
is identical to the devices in
the original background image.
Now what I'm going to do
is something I think is fun
and I think helpful
to the image.
I'm going to go to
Layers, then Layer Style.
Now remember, we're
talking about what
is labeled here as Layer One.
I'm going to create a
drop shadow, which I like.
You can play around with
the various qualities,
like angle of the
shadow, distance
of the shadow, the
spread, the size,
but watch as I change these
particular characteristics.
What you're seeing
here is a drop shadow.
OK.
I'm going to say OK.
I'm going to zoom
in a little bit
to show you what
we've done-- created
the shadow in that layer only.
I'm going to make this new
layer invisible to show
you the difference.
Here is how the background,
the original image,
looks on its own, and here
it is with the drop shadow.
So for me this looks
a little bit more
like the initial image with
its own shadows on the flatbed.
One more thing.
I'm going to convert the image
into a more horizontal image.
Sometimes you want
to add more space,
either making it more
vertical or horizontal,
to fit it for a certain format.
So the color with which we
want to extend the image
is this color.
That needs to be in
the background box
when we increase canvas size.
OK.
I'm going to go to the image.
Canvas Size.
And here, I think
this might work.
And if it doesn't, we
can add a little more
to change the width,
making the image longer.
Let's just go, let's make it 15.
So the algorithm will divide
the additional five inches
on both sides of the
image, keeping in mind
that the original
image is placed
in the center of that process.
And here is the revamped image.
It gives us a little
more space on both sides.
So the last thing
I'm going to show you
is just a little
bit of labeling.
So I'd like to insert
a label indicating
that this area from here
to there is a centimeter.
But before we do that,
we still have two layers.
So let's flatten the
image, so there, we're
only working with one layer.
As you see, there's only
one in the window now.
I'm going to take our
line, trying it in white.
You can try in black or
whatever color you want.
OK, that's not bad.
Let me undo this.
That's Command-Z. I want the
lines to be a little closer
to the area that I'm
connecting it to.
There's one.
There's another.
It's OK.
We're going to add
some text, which
I think I'm also going
to make in white.
And I'm going to label
it, let's say 1cm.
And then-- that's too small.
Let's see, it's 18
using your style.
Let's go to 24 points
and see how that looks.
Almost there.
I'll go back to move
it a little bit.
That should do it.
Yeah.
I like it.